the lecture I prepared for you guys
tonight is all about end games and
practical end games how to play
different kinds of endgame positions how
to make the most of your possibilities
how to learn more about the endgame and
just some really practical advice is
what I want to give you guys the game I
wanted to start with today you can see
right there is a game I played here in
the club a few months ago at the bill
right st. Louis open I'm playing white
here my opponent is the young a wonder
liang has anyone heard of this kid yeah
he's like 9 years old or maybe 10 he's a
master he's very talented young player
so the position we have here it's pretty
equal the material is even on either
side has any obvious weaknesses and it's
kind of closed up
so I played rook Jiwon it's a really
simple move I just want to put my rook
on the open file he does the same thing
I play King g3 he played Ricky eight so
basically if both sides just do nothing
the game's gonna be a draw there's no
way for either side to really break
through here as long as you don't do
anything too crazy or risky both sides
should be okay I'm not gonna take on g8
most likely because I don't want to give
him the file and he's not gonna take on
g1 because he doesn't want to give me
control of the file either so we're
basically just kind of locked in here
now I don't worry about it it's cool
but I did want to win this game
and I wouldn't be showing this game if
we just agree to a draw like that
wouldn't be it so I play 94 I think I
kind of have to play this move because
box knight on f6 is just it's defending
everything it's a perfect piece and my
knight can't really do much of anything
at all like Knight a for Knight b6 and
then what like there's there's nothing
for my knight to attack so I I came up
with one trick here and my opponent he
just fell for it he fell forward really
hard and I ended up winning this game
and the the main lesson is that you
should never relax no matter how drawn
or dead drawn you think the position is
there's always going to be tricks for
one of the side so you should always
keep your focus
I play 94 if you took I took and here if
he just plays one move a five like we
can probably agree to a draw here or
maybe black is even better you can play
a four try to attack my b3 pawn and play
rook b8 at some point but most likely
the game is going to be drawn either
side can really do a whole lot but he
played rook b8 which is a very natural
move he probably came up with the same
idea to play a5 a4 try to attack my
pawns but this move almost loses I
played rook g8 he took and I played
before this is my my one trap in the
position and the point of this move is
that I'm just trying to create a passed
pawn and because my King is closer to
the center than his King then this
passed pawn is gonna be really dangerous
so he played see takes before this is
probably not a good move he should have
done Rick c8 just trying to defend this
pawn then I'm gonna play b5 creating a
passed pawn he should take I take he
plays rook a a attacking my a to pawn I
played rugby one takes b6 ok a b7 rook
b8 and h4 this is an important move to
stop the king from coming in to g5 and
after let's say King juice and rook b6
white is much better here I'm down upon
but my B pawn is very strong I can
always take on d6 on on e5 if I want to
and but it's not quite losing yet for
black black can still fight on here the
game is not yet over
but this position is very very good for
white because my rook is very active and
once I take on d6 and I play King takes
e5 I should have the better chances here
so that was blacks best option you
played
see takes before and I played c5 so
that's my idea I just want to break
through create a passed pawn and win the
game so it takes and d6 I can also play
King takes e5 first but I think d6 is uh
is more direct so it's a better move so
White's plan here is pretty simple King
D 5 D 7 King the six king be seven and
queen or king takes e5 King F six King
g7 and I queen but you know it's kind of
it's kind of risky because I gave up two
pawns and now black has their own
counter playing the Queen side they have
their own passed pawns so this decision
is kind of its double-edged if y
miscalculates something or messes up
here then they could easily lose against
these Queen side pawns so he played a
five I there's some other lines here but
basically my idea going into all this
was that even if Black gets their Queen
side pawns down to like b2 and c2 I
should have enough time to promote my D
pawn and my F pawn and I'll show you
guys what I mean right here so let's say
rook d8 I'll take here well this is if
he just tries to defend against my pawns
in place King g7 I just go after his
pawns and if I can win this Queen side
pawns and keep my d6 pawn of course
white white is just gonna be easily
winning let's say he plays c4 so I take
the pawn c3 d78
King t6 a five so it's important here
not to rush with white the game it seems
like it's completely waiting like I'm
just gonna win his truck next but it's
not so simple like King g7 rook b8 and
King takes F sound is very important if
I just make a queen here I'm sorry
it takes I take he plays a four this is
really not so easy because black spawns
are pretty dangerous here you guys know
like if two pawns get to the sixth rank
or the third rank a rook just can't stop
them like they're too strong I'll play
here C 2 V 3 and black wins black wins
the game so that's why it's important to
first take this f7 pawn so that once I
win black's rook and it can also push my
F pawn and make a clean and it just it
just works out like I was trying to
calculate this during the game I had a
pretty good idea that it worked but uh
you know it was pretty it was pretty
risky so I'll play here if black Queens
I'll just take it and make it Queen so
they have to play C 2 so I'll Queen
black takes I take Queen Queen and it's
made in probably three moves King g5
queen of six mate right so this is the
whole idea this is the whole idea of
before I break through I make a pass
pawn and get a second pass pawn white
gets counter play but white is just in
time to to Queen so this is kind of the
point of this whole this first position
is that the first mission we saw was
completely drawn just that equal and now
things are crazy so you can never relax
during a chess game if my opponent just
play this a5 move earlier not allowing
me this b4 break you know we could have
shaken hands right there but now that
the position has gone is so complicated
it's very easy to lose this with black
and indeed it as a losing position so he
played a 5 here he just wants to get his
pawns rolling I took on e5 see for King
f6
a 4 and here I played rook out for this
is actually a mistake
I should have just continued with the
previous idea just King takes up
promote both pawns and and make the
black King but I figured rook f4 was
just a simpler solution
I should mention we both only had like a
few minutes here so you know I I was
just looking for the easiest way to win
so I thought rook f4 I'm gonna win one
of these ponds and then if my route can
contain blacks Queen side pawns then I
should be able to promote the pawn in my
king when blacks rook and win the game
so he played b3 I took I took here
he played rook g3 he should have played
rook d8 this was his final final chance
and this is the reason why my deal with
rook F foreign taking one of these pawns
a mistake because it gives black this
last chance to save the game so I play
King g7 I got to keep this d6 pawn now
he plays rook b8 he wants to promote so
root K one is the only move B to be 1
and now rook b3 this is the key idea he
had to find now is rook gets active and
it can give me these annoying checks
along the the 3rd rank so I'll play d7
Rickey 3 check and he goes back if I
play King g8 he'll give me checks but I
basically can't promote the D pawn
anymore
eventually I have to take this pawn
he'll take care and I don't know this
position it's close to winning for white
but it's not as winning as the position
we saw before when white is just mating
with a queen and rook right so it still
takes a little bit of work if I'm gonna
win this game
fortunately for myself in this position
I don't have to play d7 I can play this
move f6 and if I this position in the
game I'm not sure if I would find this
move whole play would but after this
move f6 white is again winning the two
pawns are too strong something like this
f7 and the pawn promotes so that was
blacks last chance he had to find a way
to activate his rook like with this idea
rook b3 and rook III check instead he
played rugby 3
but it's pretty much hopeless now
because my pawn is too strong and I've
found a way to just end the game
immediately
I played rook e8 threatening checkmate
on h8 you played King h7 and I played d7
so if black plays b2 I'll Queen feel
Queen and then Queen h8 is mate so I
wanted to show that game again because
it I think it shows some really cool
in-game principles the first one is that
the active King is pretty much the most
important thing the reason that all this
worked for white is because miking is
close to the center close to this D pawn
and blacks king is out of the game and
bak just didn't have enough time to
bring his King in and because of that
it's like White's playing with an extra
piece and I'm able to promote my pawns
and win the game ok so the second game I
wanted to show here I'm playing black
I've got two pieces versus a rook and
pawn and well let's open it up a bit
like what do you guys know about these
kinds of positions when you have two
pieces versus a rock or a rook versus
two pieces who knows any kind of
principles or ideas what's the most
important thing in these kinds of
positions
go for it yeah if you're the side with
the rooks you ought to be really careful
because Knights give fork and bishops
also give double attack so I guess one
thing you say is like keep your rooks on
the light score so you don't get fourth
bite of this show another important
thing is that actually activity is just
the most important thing whichever side
is the more active pieces is probably
the stronger side and they have good
winning chances if both rooks were on
the seventh rank and really active and
white could push their a pawn down the
board black would be in serious trouble
and conversely if black strip got really
active and was able to create threats
against White's pawns and King then
black would be on top so whenever you're
playing these kinds of positions you
need to care less about material and
more about how active your pieces are
and whether you can actually create
threats so in this position the best
move for black would have been rook a
eight I just I don't let this a pawn
advance I'm gonna play maybe rook a3
next I activate my rook and it's pretty
similar to what happened in the game but
black is doing really well here all my
pieces are super active but I made a
mistake here I played rook c8 attacking
this pawn and here I assumed that why
should defend this pawn with a move like
rook before and my opponent made the
same assumption any played rook before
but this is a pretty terrible mistake
the best move here is a for White has to
give up this pawn play rook a to and now
White's a pawn is pretty dangerous and
black has to find a way to defend
against this pawn with their pieces so
like I have to make me move I Brooke
back and do something like this so I'm
able to stop the pawn but know this
position is really unclear because
White's rooks are active the pawn is
always dangerous and black can't really
do anything without allowing this pawn
to to pass through so this is what my
opponent should have done and if you
found all these moves the game would
probably be drawn the thing is like
neither side can really do anything why
can always try to create threats with
his rooks
for instance rook c2 is one idea here
pinning my knight to my rook and black
always has to watch out for this a pawn
so this would have been a really tricky
position to play as it happened my
opponent assumed he had to defend this
pawn and he played rook before so I
played Knight f5 threatening Knight e3
check and Knight takes e4 rookie - I
attack this rook and now as rook is on
the a4 Square and this is just um this
is probably like the worst position for
the rook is blocking its own pawn and
it's incredibly passive like you
couldn't pick a worse square for this
rook to be on the board so I think Blanc
is already doing really really well so I
play Bishop before rookie for Bishop c5
and this is kind of a perfect position
for a black here both pieces are in
really good squares the knight is
controlling all the squares in the
center the bishop is controlling some
important diagonals and what's really
important is that both pieces are
defended there aren't outposts what this
means is that my rook is now free to do
whatever it wants and white can't attack
either of these pieces if they play move
like g4 attacking my knight it won't be
the end of the world because my knight
will always have the d4 square or the e3
Square but meanwhile white is making
more weaknesses on the King side and
that's not something that they really
want to do so I think this is like an
ideal position for black when you have
two pieces versus the rook you want to
just find really good squares for your
pieces where they can't be attacked and
they're contributing to controlling you
know the whole board so my opponent
played rook a five blocks next move is
just going to be like rook b8 rook B to
start attacking White's King and start
messing with White's position here the
thing is is that black is basically up a
piece I have three pieces white us two
pieces so whatever I attack I'm probably
gonna win if I can coordinate all my
pieces because of that you know this
position is really difficult for white
so over okay five rook b8 rook b5 and of
course Ricca hey when you've got two
pieces versus a rook and you also have a
rook of your own it's really rare that
you're gonna want to trade rooks in this
position I want to keep a rope because I
need a piece
can move up and down and left and right
and this is a good way to continue just
play Brooke hey don't trade rooks so
rook b2 and rook a3 I actually could
have won the game immediately here I
could have played a 93 check and if the
King moves to h1 I play 91 so I tacked
the rook and I'm threatening and I'd
have to check winning the exchange and
then I'd be up at peace but I missed
this you know it's kind of you don't
often play 91 in a game and it's a
winning move so I wasn't really looking
for it instead I just played rookie 3 I
figured I would just win the game slowly
just activate my pieces start attacking
white spawns and the game is probably
going to be over soon so he played a
four I played rook c3 he played a four I
could play rook a3 here to attack this
pawn but then he's gonna play
rikiei check and rook a eight and then
he's gonna start pushing his pawn a5 a6
a7 and I feel like I don't have to
really deal with this I can just let's
start attacking him and my text should
come faster so after a four I just
played h4 I'm threatening to take on g3
and if white plays g4 here I'm gonna
play 93 check and take one of white
spots so he played rook a to only now my
opponent realized that he has to start
creating threats at any cost so he plays
this move rook a to to start pushing his
a pawn he wants to play a5 a6 and queen
it's kind of too late now now all my
pieces are super active they're
perfectly placed and my threats just
come in first to the to the white king
so he should have of course played this
move a four way back when before any of
my pieces were coordinated so now it's
just it's just too late so I take it
took with the knight 85 so now this
positions a little bit tricky for black
because if I don't you know create some
serious threat to White's King soon he's
gonna Queen this part
so I found a good move here I found
Knight h5 the point is I want to take
this pawn on f4 with check and then my
pieces are going to be really well
coordinated to attack White's King he
just doesn't have enough time like if a6
I'll take care and as you can see the
King's kind of running out of squares
like King h1 check and back and at least
one this pawn or I give mate on on the
eighth-ranked or if King f1 I can play
record straight and then check and I win
the rook but what I wanted to point out
to you guys is that even if even if I
don't have all these mating patterns
with the rook Knight and Bishop if I
just play a position like this rook
takes c4 for instance a7 and I just give
up my bishop well the knight and three
pawns for the rook it's just a winning
endgame I mean it's a pretty simple one
ever even if we trade rooks because
Knight and three pawns just it's just
too much there's no way the rook can
contain all the all the extra material
so you always want to keep this in the
back of your head it's kind of like a
plan B going into all this when I
thought about this move h4 I was
thinking that once I went all white
spawns is that even if I don't find some
checkmater away to win White's rook at
the very least at the very very least I
can give up my bishop and I'll have a
knight and three pawns versus a rook and
that will be an endgame I can just win
it'll take 2025 more moves but I'm sure
I can win it so you always want to have
this in the back of your head like a
plan B knowing that you can always go
into the safe position with them a
winning material advantage as it
happened I do have enough counter play
here to just cause a lot of grief to
White's King so I was able to just
calculate pretty accurately and find
some good moves here I played f5 to
attack White's rook check rotate seven
and I played rugby three check kind of a
funny line years I can also just play
now
takes it for and just g5 this was good
enough for a win the point is is that
White's King is intimating net and
whites just not in time to do anything
just g3 check and look-see one mate so I
could have gone for this as well I
decided to play route g3 check King h2
or chief for I came up with a stride to
play rook h4 check and then the King
moves then I play Knight takes a four
and then I win White's rook so I figured
this was good enough for the win and it
was a six check check
I take care and the game is basically
over
if white played rook b7 for instance to
get out of this threat I have a really
cool mate here I just give check check
check and that's made so the point of
this position of course was to show you
guys some important principles about
playing two pieces versus a rook the
most important thing of course is to get
your pieces on good active squares and
try to create threats of your with your
rook and Bishop at night and for the
side that's playing with the with the
extra rook of course you need to realize
that once black coordinates their pieces
really well you're going to be in big
trouble
so after rook c8 here of course my
opponent should play a four and
immediately go for this counter play
with the a pawn and blacks just not
ready to do anything to White's King yet
as you can see so cool any questions on
that
anything I've talked about so far all
right sweet
yeah
did you say Knight f4 oh that's right
yeah that happened right here
yeah this could have just ended the game
immediately night gifts check King has
to move either to h3 or h1 then 91 and
and I'm just gonna have an extra bishop
this would have been the simplest way to
and of course but then you know we
wouldn't have seen the rest of the
wonderful game so what can you do oh I'm
sorry the point is that life is gonna
play night off to check next no matter
what forking the the king and the rook
on e4 and I'm also attacking the rook on
b2 so no matter where this rook goes I'm
going to play Knight f2 check and when
the rook on e4 and then the extra bishop
you know all of whites pawns are
separated and weak should be no problems
for black to win that game cool anything
else
yeah go for it
yeah
yeah you want to take this pawn and then
win back the rook with this cheque right
well this session it's probably winning
for black because White's pawn is only
on a4 and I can bring my King in and I
can probably win this pawn but I feel
like it'll just take a long time but I
think this is winning too just out of
principle I don't really want to trade
rooks just to make things easier for
myself I was pretty sure after h4 I I
can create all these threats against
White's King and it should be good I can
also play Knight III check here and just
take this pawn like that but here I
figured I'd rather just have my knight
on the King side attacking White's King
rather than then go for this pawn so
this is actually another game I played
in the club here I'm playing black and
the position looks pretty normal
even material the only difference here
is that black has two bishops versus a
bishop and Knight and this is actually a
pretty this is a pretty sizable
advantage or perk of the position it's
it's really good to have two bishops in
a very simplified endgame like this the
center is open both bishops have these
nice diagonals that they can work with
and having the two bishops is definitely
an advantage in this kind of position so
I wanted to show you again show you guys
this game because I think that it can be
really useful to see how to use the two
bishops and sort of win again an endgame
that looks kind of equal and pretty
close to being drawn so the first thing
I did here was I I traded this this rook
off I figure both of white strokes look
really nice in the center so whenever
your opponent's pieces are better than
yours then you always want to trade them
off now the white house 1 rook that's
not as much not as much pressure in the
center so I just played Bishop e6 here
so white circus developed
but it's really not a big deal there's
nothing that the white road can really
do and my record can get into the game
next so my opponent play rook d1 I
played Bishop e5 g3 this is kind of an
interesting move by my opponent he's
basically trying to get me to take this
knight on c3 and double his pawns and
and but I could do this I can double the
pawns and try to win this endgame
because white spawns are weak maybe
bring my king to the Queen side and try
to win here but I figured it would be
better to just keep my Bishop because of
position like this it's very good for
black but it's probably not winning if
white defends really accurately for
instance they can play a move like c5
and then rook b1 and attack might be
seven pawn and if I trade a pawn or two
and you know the material remains equal
then it's gonna be really hard for black
to win I'd rather just keep my powerful
dark squared Bishop on the board because
this bishop is going to control the
Queen side and the King side and it's
going to be very hard for white to deal
with this bishop because they don't have
a dark squared Bishop to sort of
counteract its power
so I played g5 I play g3 they want to
play f4 and gain some space so I just
play g5 to stop them from this advance
yeah
no that's that's a great question I
could play this move I just like this is
a perfectly fine move eventually I ended
up trading works like this I just wanted
to keep rooks on the board for now
because I figured keeping the rooks on
can't possibly hurt me like if I get my
rook really active with the two bishops
it should be a really powerful piece if
I can't make any progress
then I'll trade rooks and play that
position so here I'm really I'm not sure
yet whether I can win this game or not
after playing this game out now I know
like it's not that difficult for me to
win this position back then I wasn't
sure if I should keep the rooks on or
off so I figured I'll keep the rook on
keep things flexible then if White's
rook is super active or it's stopping me
from making any more progress I'll trade
rooks and then play that position does
that make sense well and for the moment
you know white shark can't come to my
seventh rank it really can't create any
threats here so I should be okay so G 3
g5
F 3 my opponent just wants to get his
King to the center of the board which is
a good idea play King f8 and here I just
played b6 I can trade rooks again and
this is probably good enough for the
wind because my king is very close to
the Queen side I just want to bring my
King to like you know a4 if you let me
and just go after White's pawns probably
white will play B form and then I'll
I'll attack White's pawns with my
bishops and it should be good enough for
the win but here I just played b6 just
to control this square on c5 and just
keep everything under control the thing
about playing these positions where
you're slightly better you have the two
bishops or you have some other very
small advantages that you just want to
keep things under control you don't have
to win the game right away just take
your time don't give your opponent any
chances
try to restrict all these pieces
including their Knights
and then eventually you can improve your
position slowly and eventually you'll
win the game
so I played b6 my next one is just going
to be f5 to gain even more space
b3 f5 and here I can play a five and try
to try to tickle these pawns here create
a weakness but I figured I might as well
just play Rex d8 now I think my pawns on
the kingside look good my king is closer
to the Queen side and if I trade Rux it
should be a pretty easy one so he plays
rook to e3 this is a good move he says
that if we're gonna trade rooks and at
least he'll get his knight to d3 or
he'll get his bishop out so I just
played a five because I'm not forced to
trade works either so I can improve my
position he plays a four I put rook d4
so I'm just refusing to trade rooks
if he wants to trade works that's great
I'll get my bishop to d4 but for the
moment I'm ready to play King d6 king c5
King before and go after his Queen side
pawns this is like one of the main
advantages of the two bishops it just
you just control all the squares the
dark squared bishop is such a strong
piece in this position that White's
really in in some serious trouble so he
played King g2 King t6 and here finally
he just White has nothing to do here he
just has to trade drugs so I took and he
played 93 and here I played b5 so the
point of b5 is to UM is to break through
actually after this move my opponent
just resigned he didn't really want to
play anymore it's just kind of strange
because the the material is even and it
looks like looks like why should just
play on right I mean I would play on in
this position but it's actually not such
a strange decision if you sort of just
look at all the lines that are that are
possible for instance if white take this
pawn and I take and they take and I take
on b3 blacks a pawn is just going to
Queen there's uh there's nothing white
special neither King can do
this pawn like let's say Knight c1 there
should be five and there's just nothing
here a 4 a 3 a 2 I'm gonna win a piece
and with an extra piece I'll I'll win
the game of course so I can't take on b5
you can move as knight like 91 but then
I'll take or all attack his night and if
king f2 I saw this during the game I can
even trade
my Bishop off and win this e4 pawn so as
you can see I'm only willing to train my
Bishop if I get some tangible advantage
here of course I'm winning the c4 pawn
I'm probably gonna win the a4 pawn my
king is so much more active that I don't
need the two bishops anymore to in this
game and trading the bishop off just
makes things simpler I take on c4 next
I'll take on a4 in so winning game if
they keep their night pretty much the
same thing king c5 and I'm just winning
the c4 pawn so my opponent to his credit
after this move b5 you like you just
didn't see a way to really continue the
game he saw these lines he realized that
black only has to play like two more
good moves and the game is over and he
resigned so are there any any questions
on that
who would resign in this position
that's the thing
a good rule of thumb is if you were to
switch sides and you could win the
position against anybody in the world
with no trouble then you should resign
if you don't see how your opponent is
going to win then make him show you and
you'll learn something so whenever I'm
busted against the Grandmaster I want to
resign and like show him some respect
but I also just want to play on to see
how he would win that position because
if we were to switch sides I'm not sure
I could beat him but you know then they
beat me and then I learned a thing or
two about converting you know like these
end games but you know in all honesty
but the game is pretty much won here and
um there's just like there's just no
tricks left here for white even though
then I is such a tricky piece there's
just nothing that I can really do like
rings are king in and and they win
they're they're Queen side pawns okay
cool well I have one final position for
you guys
so again I'm playing black here and
actually let me just give you guys a
moment to like try to figure out what's
going on here because it's a pretty
complicated position
so black has got this pawn on c2 this is
a pretty strong pawn and whites and
whites in pretty big trouble here
fortunately for them the pawn is
blockaded there's no way black and
immediately promote the pollen or attack
White's Bishop enough times to make him
move away and then promote upon so black
needs to black still has a lot of work
to do before they win this game yeah so
let's just let's just go on with the
game I played my day for my idea is to
play Knight c3 and the knight a to
attacking the bishop or maybe even 91
blocking the rook from controlling c1
and win the game that way and I'm also
just improving my knight so he plays
Knight before
in 93 so can anyone see why ye can't
take this pawn on c2
yeah so which move is that yeah so white
plays Knight takes seat - Hey - I think
someone said it but yeah you got the
right idea
so Knight take c2 Knight a - and I'm
attacking whites Knight and whites bish
I was lost on c1 so it's actually not a
huge deal it's like one simple trick but
a lot of times when when I play these
end games I forget to look at very
simple things like that and and maybe
I'll even like reject the move like
Knight c3 because my pawn is hanging and
then I'll just forget about it but just
because it's an endgame you should
always look for little tricks to help
your position so Knight c3 you play King
F 191 and he played Knight a - like if
he takes this pawn I just take and then
I I win the piece so that would be a
pretty easy one so you play Knight a -
and I played rook a4 I just take the
bishop right away and play rook c3 so
the idea here is that the c2 pawn is not
going to win the game for me immediately
but it's gonna sort of tie up all of
White's pieces that my rook and Knight
can start attacking White's other pawns
if anyone is sort of like the principle
of - weaknesses this is pretty much
what's going on at play here like White
has to defend against the C to pawn make
sure it doesn't promote and meanwhile
blacks rook and Knight are just gonna
attack all of whites pawns which are
practically defenseless so a position
like this would be very close to winning
for black instead I just played rook a
four I'm just attacking the a three
pointer in a different way I just want
to take on c1 and then take on a three
so King - there's really not a whole lot
I can do here he just wants to bring his
King in and try to defend that way so I
took on c1
and I took on a three and I play tricks
III here so a black one upon but the
position is actually not that simple yet
my pieces are they look weird and they
are because they're just uncoordinated
like the 91
it's a strange piece and the rook is for
now just protecting the c2 upon so
rookie to I play King f7 this is just a
way to move because white doesn't have
any useful moves and that's something
you guys should try to remember for the
endgame it's like you have this
advantage of the c2 pawn white has no
past pawns they have no active pieces
they have no counter play you can make a
safe move like king f7 and just just to
pass the move to your opponent a lot of
times they'll just blend or something
because they they don't have anything to
do that's actually what happened right
here he played nine a two and night
before which is which is a blunder but
we'll look at that in case of night c1 I
think this move g5 is actually really
good the point is that I'm just fixing
White's pawn on h3 and white still has
nothing to do but eventually what's
going to happen is I'll play something
like d4 and maybe they'll take and then
I'll take on f3 and then I'll take on h3
for instance or you know if they take
the pawn I can play Knight takes c3
Knight c4 and White's pausing the kinks
are just gonna fall so that's the second
way of like winning this game the first
way is to try and promote your pawn
using your two pieces the second way is
to just give up this pawn but in the
meantime you win all of whites other
pawns as it happened my opponent played
night before which is a blunder
can anyone see how black can win in this
position
so rook takes III and then what if
Knight takes c2
well you can just trade rooks and then
you have an extra pawn and you have a
knight endgame and it should be wedding
that's definitely good enough but um
Knight takes c3 is even better with the
same idea the point is that White's King
has to protect the C 1 square so it's
not really defending the c3 pawn if Y
plays rook takes c3 I'll take the wreck
and then the King can't recapture
because I queen but good job that's
exactly right
the other point here is that if Knight
takes C - I'll take and I'll trade and
this same game is pretty easily winning
or if I'm not too confident about my
King and pawning games I'll just take
this pawn in that pond and and the game
will be over anyways
so my opponent played rook e1 and here
it's very important not to uh not so
relaxed because you have two extra pawns
but you got to stay focused till the end
of the game until the clock has stopped
like you just can't let your opponent
off the hook so you got to play just
what you believe it to be the best moves
and don't let them off the hook so d4
you play nice e6 and I can play rook a4
here defending the pawn but I figured
that with my rook Knight into pawns I
probably have some winning combination
here a way to promote the pawn or do
something pretty strong so I was able to
find it I just play Knight c4 check King
takes and rook c3 check so if the King
moves to be one I'll play ninety two
check and I win the night and if King d1
that Knight B to check of course and I
win the night so seeing that my opponent
of course resign so the point of that
position was to show you guys that even
though you have this really strong pawn
in c2 you always need to look for
possible tactics like Knight takes c3
but if your opponent doesn't let you do
anything if they defend really solidly
then you have to look for a way to
create more weaknesses in their position
or go after the other weaknesses in
their position in this case the h3
so why here it really has nothing to do
they take the pawn I win the e3 pawn and
then my rook and Knight are incredibly
active and whites King is now misplaced
on the Queen side because it was dealing
with the C pawn and blacks pieces just
take all of whites pawns on the Kings
side and we're then we're all set so I
hope you guys enjoyed it hope you guys
stay for the next lecture starts pretty
soon and I'll see you guys soon